- [Instructor] Carbon monoxide
will react with hydrogen gas
to produce methanol.
Let's say that the
reaction is at equilibrium
and our job is to figure out
which direction the
equilibrium will shift,
to the left, to the right, or not at all,
as we try to make changes to
the reaction at equilibrium.
For example, if we add some hydrogen gas
to our reaction at equilibrium,
we're increasing the concentration
of one of our reactants.
According to the Le Chatelier's principle,
the net reaction will
move in the direction
that decreases the stress
placed on the system.
So if the stress is increased amount
of one of the reactants,
the equilibrium will shift to the right
to get rid of some of that reactant.
In part B, some methanol is removed.
So if we're decreasing the
concentration of our product,
the equilibrium's gonna shift
to make more of our product,
therefore, the equilibrium
will shift to the right.
Next, the volume is increased
on the reaction at equilibrium.
And if we increase the volume,
we decrease the pressure,
therefore, we could consider the stress
to be decreased pressure.
Le Chatelier's principle says
the net reaction is gonna go
in the direction that relieves the stress.
So if the stress is decreased pressure,
the net reaction is going to
shift to increase the pressure.
And we can figure out
which direction that is
by looking at the balanced equation.
On the reactant side,
there's one mole of gas
and two moles of gas
for a total of three moles of gas.
On the product side, there's
only one mole of gas.
So there's three moles of gas on the left
and only one mole of gas on the right.
Since the net reaction is going to try
to increase the pressure,
the equilibrium shifts to the left,
toward the side that's gonna
form more moles of gas,
therefore increasing the pressure.
Next, we try adding some neon gas
to our reaction mixture at equilibrium.
Well, neon gas is an inert gas,
which means it doesn't react
with any of our reactants or products.
And if we look at the expression
for the reaction quotient Qp,
neon gas is not included.
Therefore, adding neon gas is not going
to change the value for Qp,
so the reaction remains at equilibrium.
So the answer is there's no shift
when an inert gas is added.
And that might sound a
little strange at first
because adding neon gas means
that the total pressure would increase,
the total pressure since
we're adding a gas.
However, the partial
pressures stay the same.
So the partial pressures for methanol
and carbon monoxide and hydrogen
gas actually stay the same
and therefore Q doesn't change.
Next, we add a catalyst to
our reaction at equilibrium.
Catalysts speed up reactions
by lowering deactivation energy.
However, the catalyst is gonna
speed up that the forward
and the reverse reactions
by the same amount
and therefore the reaction
remains at equilibrium.
So there's no shift
when a catalyst is added
to a reaction at equilibrium.
And then in part F,
let's try decreasing the temperature
on the reaction at equilibrium.
Well, this reaction is exothermic
because Delta H is less than 0,
so we can treat heat as a product.
So we go ahead and write
heat on the product side.
If we treat heat like a product,
decreasing the temperature
is like decreasing the amount
of our product, therefore,
the net reaction will move to the right
to make more of the product.
Whether that reaction moves to the right,
you can think about that being an increase
in the amount of products
and therefore a decrease
in the amount of reactants.
And when you increase the products
and decrease the reactants,
you increase the value for
the equilibrium constant.
Therefore, lowering the
temperature causes an increase
in the equilibrium constant
for an exothermic reaction.
Note that changing the temperature
in part F is the only change
that actually changed
the equilibrium constant.
So in all the other ones, in A through E,
the equilibrium constant
stayed the same value.